join us with
um
welcome counselors to this meeting of
council and i wish you all a very happy
new year
this is a public meeting being streamed
live to to youtube
and via the council's website the
meeting is also being recorded for the
purposes of the minutes
i have been advised that the live stream
is now up and running
if for any reason the public cannot hear
or see the meeting over the live stream
we will adjourn until the connection has
been reestablished
can i ask the governance manager to
explain the procedure for the meeting
and to confirm the members and officers
present
thank you thank you chair
so um on the call today um we have
all members of council by a few that
we're going to put through
for apologies um
in terms of the meeting of council
members are advised to address and
behave
as if in the council chamber please be
aware that this meeting
is being streamed and recorded
a reminder for all members to speak
through the chair remaining muted when
not invited to do so
um to indicate to speak please write
speak within the chat bar
and if members could limit contacting
the team via the chat
function rather than contacting other
members that would be helpful
i'm going to turn on closed captions for
the meeting and i'm also going to record
this meeting just here
i don't know what happened wrong number
or something
um i'm just going to click the record
button now this meeting is being
recorded
okay uh just one final reminder for
members if you could introduce yourself
um before speaking for example counselor
x representing
y board um counselor roger hall has uh
just joined
the meeting for the members
to note and also in this meeting we do
have
a number of officers present we have uh
lee hicken who's the
paid service karen hansen who's one of
our strategic directors
jane death who's the head of um sorry
the section 151 officer
and assisting the chair and vice chair
in the chamber
is sarah sternberg who's the monitoring
officer
thank you chair
nikki can i just say i've just gone on
the chat man it's just coming to you is
that okay
just says private
um yes thank you um yes so so members
should be able to contact me through the
chat function
um but we have uh disabled um for
chatting
members through the chat function to
each other for this meeting
so sorry will you pass that on to the
chair then if who wants to speak
yes of course
are there any more apologies for absence
chair apologies have been received from
councillor carol huckabee
um micro and councillor jackie ridgeway
there's one more there's one more
apology
stone
did you get that nikki at least thank
you
declarations of interest members who
have interest should have declared them
to the governance
manager in advance of the meeting we
have an item
on today's agenda in relation to the
killer
leisure center and the monitoring
officer has advised that killer marsh
parish councillors should declare a
significant other interest
in this item of business can members
please indicate if they have any
interest to declare
councillor potts was and council cover
indicating their wish to speak
council parts sorry i was just to
declare that i do have an interest
in item number 14 on the agenda
elsa bone
yes
counselor counselor kevin
i ted yeah i would also declare an
interesting item 14.
the counselor club is indicating his
wish to speak
counselor lewis
well thank you chair um i'm going to
declare an interest in item
nine i shall remain in for the debate um
but i don't think i should be able to
vote on that but perhaps the
legal officer can consider and advise me
on that one please
thank you
in your packs you will have the minutes
of the previous two meetings of council
may i remind members of the con that the
content of the minute
documents can only be discussed in
relation to the accuracy and not for
debating please can i have a mover to
accept the minutes of the last meeting
as a true and accurate record
council council armitage
yeah cancer trail is indicating his wish
to speak
councillor dale thank you jay yeah happy
to move the minutes and just to note
also that i think councillor
pat bone and council club would also
want to declare the interest in the
killer march paper as well
i'm not sure that they were able to
raise their hand
right
so is that motion on both sides just the
first one chair
[Music]
lamar mr maher mr marindija
uh now it's just simply to say there are
two sets of minutes before council today
uh is the motion to move on both sets of
minutes or just the first set of minutes
um i'm happy to move both
chair if that's if that's easier thank
you
sorry nick yeah i'm trying to put in
something in the
in the chat bar and it's not learning me
to do it i just want
i don't know what's what's okay with me
a moment i'll um i'll see if i can
resolve the chat bar function
so i just want i just wanted to and i
know we can't open a debate on it but
just on the minutes
castle park are you indicating your wish
to speak on the minutes
yes please that okay chet
it's just i obviously i agreed to both
the minutes
uh i just on the first one there's still
a couple issues that have not been
resolved yet
and on the second one uh on the uh on
the uh whatever it is ceo 62
on the appointments and advisory groups
the uh the extra bullet point
about uh bringing the findings back to a
council meeting
have we got a date for that uh i thought
he might come to this one
that's all thank you
did you hear that uh yes can i just
clarify
councillor parker you mean the uh report
on the six-month rule
etc yes that we asked for we put an
extra bullet point in
anyway you required me to do a report
which i have actually drafted and we'll
be going out with the papers for the
february meeting
okay okay sarah thank you okay
could we have a second please
counselor armitage
yeah i'll second it thank you
joe would you like me to issue a poll
yes
he remembers i've issued a poll to you
um asking you
to vote for against or abstain to
approve the minutes of the meeting of
meetings of council held on the 12th of
october and the 19th november
jeff you can just bear with me while
those results come in
joey do you have a few members still
left to vote
however at the moment we're at 45 votes
with a hundred percent so the vote would
be carried
so with your commission there's two four
in the chamber as well
and i'm sharing the results on the
screen so 45 on the
on the at home vote
so that would be carriage chair
thank you
now item four chairs announcements
prior to the season break i held a pet
photo competition which asked for a five
pound donation on entry
of an amusing photo of a pet to win a 50
pounds marks and spencer's voucher
we had a number of entrants and i found
it very difficult to choose between them
i uh our ever with difficulty mindtap
i have chosen finn as a winning pet
this raised 40 pounds from my chosen
charities
i also would like to say thank you to
the parish council
who have responded to my um
letter asking for a donation to my
charity if that was possible
and i'd like to say thank you very much
for those that
have responded
can i can i now invite council dale to
give the leaders
announcements
thank you uh very much chair can i start
by wishing you all
a very happy new year um i hope that
you've had a good break over the
christmas
period despite the restrictions and that
you're able to catch up with friends and
family
even if not able to see them in person
i'm sure you'll all
join me in hoping that 2021 is a far
better year than
2020 and that it will be the year that
we will see the back of this dreadful
virus
while the news of the approval of the
three vaccines is helping to fuel that
sense of hope
a further national lockdown is clearly
not what any of us will have wanted to
greet the new year
with we continue to meet on a
cross-party basis
to ensure that the council and ricknald
homes are doing all that we can
to respond to the pandemic to support
our residents and businesses
and to continue to deliver the services
that our communities rely upon
our communications channels have all
been updated to reflect the current
guidance and advice
and we've reached out to those
vulnerable residents who we supported
during the first lockdown to offer any
assistance that they may need
as well as doing some phone calls to a
random sample
of the wider list of residents who
registered with us in the first lockdown
the team have reported back that other
than bits and pieces of advice and
guidance and support
the residents we've spoken to remain in
good spirits
and are very grateful for the support
and we will keep checking in with them
over the coming weeks once again
officers have been checking that care
homes around the district
know that we are here for them should
they need any help
officers have also been working
extremely hard to get the support grants
out to businesses who have been
either been closed or severely impacted
by the recent local restrictions and
national lockdown
as of last week over 1100 grants
have been issued totaling 1.3 million
pounds covering the period since we
entered tier 2 back in october
um details of the grants covering the
tier four restrictions and the latest
lockdown
are still coming through so please do
bear with us
um while we get those grants set up as
soon as possible
it's fair to say that the grants
landscape is a complex one
and i know that some of us will have
businesses in our patches who have some
queries about that
if that is the case then please don't
hesitate to contact either myself or
councillor parking
and we will be very happy to look into
any of those issues
many of you will be aware that the
charlie park leisure centre opened on
friday as the first
large vaccination center in a public
space in derbyshire
i'm extremely proud that the council is
supporting the vital role out of the
vaccine in this way
but equally i am determined that we must
try to do more
we have been in regular contact with the
ccg to offer support wherever required
and also to put forward possible
additional venues
some on behalf of our parish and town
council colleagues that we would like to
be
to see being used to vaccinate our
communities
i will gladly keep council updated on
this hugely important issue
i'm conscious that we have a busy agenda
so i won't speak for too much longer
i just have two for further points i
wish to make
the first is a thank you i i want to say
a huge thank you to
to all of you as our elected members as
well as our fantastic staff
and staff at ricknold homes for
everything that you are doing to support
our communities
through this incredibly difficult time
equally i'd like to thank our residents
and businesses
for all that they uh are doing to follow
the rules and guidelines so closely
and for doing our bit to get back on top
of the virus
as the prime minister has said we are in
the midst of some
of the hardest weeks but there is light
at the end of the tunnel and we need to
keep
working towards that in particular i
want to say
a big thank you to councillor powell
councillor ruth
uh councillor bacca councillor barca
councillor funnel
and councillor windley for all of their
work in the care of christmas appeal
which was absolutely fantastic in
raising much needed funds
to support that project to get christmas
presents to
residents in care homes and i know from
some of the feedback it's been
very very gratefully received and also
obviously to thank
all of the officers from across the
council and ricknall for all of the work
they did in that it really was a
marvelous piece of cross council
working and i'm really really pleased
with the results of that
and finally just to point out that of
all the organizations that have been
impacted by covid
charities in particular have been hit
hard and the difficulties in carrying
out fundraising activities has meant
that some fantastic causes have
struggled to gain
support now i know that the chair counts
rancliffe
has been doing a fantastic job in trying
to raise much needed funds for her two
chairs appeal charities alzheimer's
research uk
and the national deaf children society
but understandably has been impacted by
the restrictions over the past 10 months
so before closing chair i'd like to make
a final a plea that all members do
whatever they can to support the chairs
appeal
and to promote it in your local
communities wherever and whenever
the opportunity arises thank you very
much chair
thank you can i confirm that no public
questions have been submitted so we
shall now move on to the next
item
can i invite councillor parking
portfolio
holder for finance to present the report
thank you very much chair uh yes uh
councillor park in
portfolio finance and also representing
drumfield
north um the uh
this report um we're presenting the
annual audit letter and
uh this is relating to the uh
year 2019 slash 2020
uh from a financial perspective so uh
this report is from the council's
external auditor
mazars and and this is for
the council to know mazars presented
their audit findings to the audit
committee
on the 30th of september and issued an
unqualified audit option
opinion sorry on the financial
statements
uh on the 30th of november this year
when they presented
and i would also like to thank
the team in finance for
the immense amount of work that they
were doing at this particular during
this
particular period whilst the audit was
going on the audit itself
is a large piece of work for the finance
team within this council
but they also had an awful lot more on
their plate as well
as councillor uh councillor dale has
mentioned
with uh with the with the covey grants
and all sorts of announcements being
made during that period too
so um i i'd like to move recommendation
at
6 1 and 6.1 that the council considers
and notes the attached report
from the council's external auditors
masters
thank you thank you
we do have a secondary and counsellor
thacker
thank you chair and as the chair of the
audit scrutiny committee i can confirm
as council parking has already said that
the committee did scrutinize
this information from mazars and noted
that the value for money conclusion
did say that the council put in place
proper arrangements to secure
economy efficiency and effectiveness in
its use of resources
for the year ended 31st of march 2020
so i think the report is
self-explanatory and as such i
second the recommendations
thank you are there any comments
okay councillor barker would like to
speak on this item
councillor barker actually nikki it was
from last time and uh
i think pat kerry were going to speak on
it so i'll not steal his thunder
i was just trying to delete me speak
from
the original thing and he'd come up so
it's working now anyway that's good
the chat bar is working uh spat do you
want to
take over can you hear me
um i would only like to comment on the
fact that
it it is a letter uh
it shows no problems at the moment i
think problems will come further down
the line
i would just like to say uh i know the
work involved
with the audit and the audit letters
from past experience
and it started from a good base and it's
still continuing by the look of it
from that good base that we left you
thank you
thank you councillor parker would you
like to make any
a right of reply or comment
i have no further comment chair thank
you
we'll now move to the vote
can we have a show of hands
for all in paper
yeah that that very very pleased to be
unanimous chair
oh thank you
can i invite councillor ruff elected
member champion for mental health to
present the report
thank you chair i'm my name's diana
rather the councillor representing
womenworth ward
fellow members i hope you've all had the
opportunity to read the mental framework
documents that were sent to you
this is just phase one of the project
and is directed
at not only our workforce but also for
members
poor mental health issues are widespread
can be very disabling
and due to the present pandemic the
number of people suffering with mental
health issues are on the increase
from the action plan you can see we have
set out clear ways
forward for the council this document
has been previewed by some members of
our workforce and have received a very
positive
feedback i would like to take this
opportunity to thank
all the officers that have been involved
with this project
especially lee hicken and richard
purcell for all their hard work
we do have a stage two and stage two
will investigate how we can support our
residents across the district
also to investigate funding for
appropriate support groups
with this in mind i hope that you will
all accept and support this document
thank you thank you
is there a second uh
thank you chair um yeah just to just to
echo
uh councillor ruff's comments really
it's um
it is as she says uh just a starting
point and obviously stage two will be to
look more at how we
um sort of implement uh mental health
strategies into the services that we
deliver to residents and into our
communities in lots of different ways
and this is
much more of a internal focused
internally focused document
but actually i know from some of the um
the conversations i've had with staff
and from our employee liaison group how
well
this has been received by uh staff um
some of the comments were marvelous
we're totally happy with this
some of them felt that the training that
they'd had in terms of mental health
first aid
had been very very positive and we're
really pleased with that so
just to second this and i think this is
a really good starting point and
a good base from which we can grow and
move forward and i
echo council rush comments in thanking
some of those key officers but also
uh to thank councillor ruff for all of
her work in chairing the
uh the sort of steering group that's
seen this this through
so thank you very much a second
thank you
are there any comments
thank you chair uh council barry north
wingfield um
we welcome this this policy as a whole
and we're glad it's only phase
one of the policy and i do have a few
concerns
having to deal with this sort of thing
on a day-to-day basis within my
working role and that really relates
down to
the mental health first aiders stadius
you've relate to uh training on there i
was wondering if you could
say what sort of training they've got
and who's provided that training where
it's come from
but also what safeguarding have we got
in place
for those first aiders because obviously
if you're
um listening to somebody else that's got
a mental health issue then that can have
a negative impact on yourself as well so
i'd like to know what we're doing about
supporting
them you know what we've got in place
for those people for safeguarding
um and the other bit i was a bit
concerned about it said about
in the document under on page 52
under number nine it says mental health
first aid is that employees may wish to
speak to about issues they're
experiencing themselves or in others
um i was always of the impression that
the mental health first aiders were only
really there
for low level very low level guidance
and support
and their main strategy was to sign post
people on which i do
um is on page 51.
so my concern is and it's a national
concern out there
in the trade union movement as well is
about support
that both first aid is the mental health
first aiders get as well
um other than that you know we're we're
in support of this
uh document and then the only other
concern i've got is how are we getting
out to people
who work out in the field as opposed to
being with somebody in an office
or it's not quite an office these days
they put us
in the general work and run of the mill
how are we dealing with the digital
defined because not everybody has access
and i've noticed all the documents that
you relate to
are held on on the the network so it's
about what
what are we doing in order to get out to
those wider ranging people please
uh thank you jay i'm happy to give way
to councillor
ralph and happy to step in if she needs
me to answer any
of those particular questions around the
operational matters
actually i was going to pass it over to
you
in that case thank you councillor orphan
thank you uh chair i'll try and address
those
uh as councillor barry uh does rightly
uh allude to we we are not
the experts far from it but what we are
similar to the safeguarding arrangements
generally we're not the experts in that
either but we try and equip our
organization
with the right level of skills our role
is always primarily about
recognizing acknowledging and then uh
signposting to others
uh who are far better equipped than us
in terms of training
uh i'm a mental health first aider
myself there are a number of us who've
been trained up
to that today i can't remember the name
of the organization
who trained us now i do apologize but we
did the two-day course
which is followed by examination but
we've got over a hundred people
trained up in mental health awareness
now which is
not as intensive but it is more about
recognizing signs
symptoms understanding what to do when
presented with some of these signs and
symptoms or in fact approached by a
member
of staff and it's really about putting
in place the system
that can offer that support and signpost
to others who are better qualified
should that uh should that arise
in terms of the approach to mental
health we hope to take a similar
approach to safeguarding which i believe
has been very successful uh we as an
organization both internally but because
of
our the tentacles from our
organization i guess that spread out
into the community
it makes uh for a very good
safeguarding system where we spot things
out in the community home visits
etc when people come to the offices as
well as their own workforce
we put in place a framework that gives
us great confidence and the adults
and children safeguarding boards great
confidence in what we do as a district
council
we hope that we can follow a similar
approach for mental health
uh and part of the next phase of
development
is in fact establishing that network and
promoting that network
of mental health first aid is across the
council to the same degree that we've
got for safeguarding
generally uh i think i've covered
everything there council bear i'm
not quite sure if i'm not
thank you councillor hancock
thank you chair um again just to just to
congratulate on on this being the
document that's been prepared so far
again i would emphasize the fact of
being someone who has
a lot of experience in this area it is
clearly very much a starting point
um my concern from having read this
through
several times it is
with no disrespect to anyone very low
level um
it doesn't really pick up on complex
needs at all there's no real
identification of more complex mental
health issues in here
um and i obviously that's something we
need to be aware of we will have
colleagues who who are in that situation
um
and i i would really want to make sure
that the next step
does just kind of go towards and build
on that um
it is essential um it is a disability
a lot of the time it's actually got a
physical cause so it's something that
someone lives with for the rest of their
lives
and and this this whilst it touches upon
it it mentions it there's nothing there
to actually address the issue
we're very much dealing with depression
and anxiety and the kind of things that
will address those
but we're not moving we're not really
moving beyond there
and as i say it does seem to be a very
definite short coming in there
thank you councillor cornwell
thank you um i'm counselor susie
cornwell representing heath and homewood
and i want to pick up on the item
2.4 of this report
where the mental health group is taking
on an outward facing a mental health
lens
perspective when working with the
agencies involved
and trying to get support for people
that they are supporting
ultimately i i will be supporting this
report and i am glad that the council is
taking mental health seriously but
this is a start on a very long and a
very
complicated journey and i also question
whether the mental health group know the
challenges ahead
and do they have the skills and the
scope and the resources
to look at the issues that are needed
when working with people with mental
health
that it entails so i want to tell you a
bit of a story really
counselor maggie jones who's on on them
in this meeting and myself have had
personal experience of how the system
and the agencies have unfortunately
failed individuals
and we're hoping and we're asking this
group
when they're looking through the mental
health lens that they start to look at
solutions
such as the joining up of agencies and
be
and making sure that all the
stakeholders are
heard listened to and are involved
now councillor maggie jones lost her
robert her
own son and as a district councillor
i had a homeless person paul who lost
his life when when we were both unable
to get them the support they both so
desperately needed
when they were alive despite trying with
all
our might we were pulled from pillar to
post
fobbed off and we just couldn't get the
answers or the solutions and and it's
been a painful journey for both of us
we've been left frustrated angry and
desperately wanting solutions
and we hope have no doubt that the
system is failing individuals
with mental health and we believe it's
because the agencies are
are ultimately underfunded and that the
agencies are often
unable to help due to the data
protection act
so both of these issues result in the
individuals not
getting the support that they
desperately need despite
advocates trying absolutely everything
to raise their concerns so i i want this
group
i hope this group will seriously look at
how the multi-agencies
can have joined up thinking and that
everyone who needs to be heard
is involved we'd also like to say that
councillor maggie jones and myself are
really keen to be invited to this group
because we don't know who's
on it and who isn't so that we can share
our experiences because we want to be
part of the solution
thank you thank you councillor barker
thank you chair yeah i just want to i i
know
someone said we're good to make these
comments you know on a personal
experience and
uh just to make the point that we are
really supportive and i know it's the
the start of the
journey uh and i i just hope that you
will
we want to work together really on this
that's that's the point i want to make
if we can help and resolve some of them
issues
and i know mostly it's about our staff
which is which is great
and i know right now they've done work
in past on on a similar thing
uh which is great uh i saw tech on board
what what counselor
what jane says we've got a second name
chancellor barry said
is that uh you know we we don't want to
overload our staff
you know we're the end taking on board
everybody else's problem so
there's an issue there but ultimately we
really really want to make this way
and if we can save somebody's life at
the end of it
uh because because that's ultimately
what happens
uh then then obviously we'll support it
and and and i'm looking at you alex i
can see you on
on my screen that you're not in a little
bit so
if you do want us to get susie
especially or maggie to get more
involved
uh that'd be great thank you
thank you councillor dale
yeah uh thank you chad i was actually as
councillor cornwell was talking i was i
was going to suggest that
um that she pick it up outside with
council russ some of those issues
and council jones because you know this
isn't about politics this is about
um trying to improve uh a difficult
situation i think probably all of us
would accept that mental health services
um you know aren't in the place that
they should be um we might disagree
about the reasons for that but
uh fundamentally i think we'd all all
agree on that point and i'm sure
um council ruff and the rest of the
working group which i think is largely
officer
uh based would would welcome you know
external views so
we can certainly uh accommodate that and
proceed on that basis
but thank you jeff thank you councillor
angelique poster
thank you uh just a couple of comments
one the first time that really
uh pleased to see this strategy coming
to the council and uh
it's it's come from the commitment that
we have to our staff first and foremost
so
i i i'm just putting a caution across
that yes mental health outside the our
staff is very crucial and we
we should do everything we we we can do
to help
and play our part in helping the issues
in our community with mental health but
this strategy first and foremost is
end at our staff and i wouldn't want to
to put our room
to cast our nets so wide that we don't
do the first thing that we want we aim
to do very well
so i would say let's make sure that we
do the first step
very well and we do provide that service
to our staff
that is efficient effective and that
works and i think we do we do resolve
some of the issues that have been
highlighted maybe a bit more training
etc
uh and then space two like you said is a
wider uh
look at how we can play our part of the
council but there are plenty of agencies
that are doing
that job i'm really sorry to hear some
of the stories that have been they're
very personal but they're beyond the
remit of the district council
and beyond the remit of that strategy
this strategy i feel
and let's not forget that mental health
has completely changed over the last few
years
uh so it's it's probably going to be
different again next year and the year
after
so this strategy is a starting point but
it's also a moving document
we're not saying it's going to be the
final thing we're stopping here
it will be a moving document and it will
be improved as we go along as well
we're learning from experience as well
so uh and i'm sure that
the the both uh councillor diana ruff
and lynne james as the main
council champion will have will bear
that in mind as well and we'll have the
support of all the councils within this
chamber
but also that you know mental health
remind everybody over the last few years
there's more and more investment from
government has been put towards mental
health because it has been recognized as
one of the key issues that needs to be
improved
in all our communities so investment has
been increased
year on year and i think it will
continue to increase uh
i'm sure the lock down the copy 199
boots forward
more issues the first slowdown brought
some issues to our staff the second
lockdown will bring some
other issues and i'm sure we'll have to
deal with the
uh other matters as we go along so
this is for me it's like i said it's a
great document to start with
but we all understand here that it's not
a final document we'll be improving as
we go along as well
thank you counselor joe birkin
thank you chair um yeah again i uh i
welcome
this initiative i think it's a a good
step forward as
uh as all of my colleagues have said um
a couple of small points uh
lee mentioned the similarity to the
safeguarding
initiatives um which if i remember
correctly um
there's a uh
an invitation a need for councillors to
be
aware of safeguarding situations i
wonder whether
there are any thoughts about councils
being involved in
identifying the early stages again to
repeat council of barrie we're not
experts
by any stretch imagination but for
councillors too to have any training or
or uh or a suggestion that they may
become involved in
uh in in spotting that first um first
set of problems that individuals might
have
and to that end and also because of our
concerns about
what it means to staff which again
counselor barriers explain and
and were expanded upon would it be
possible to get a summary of what those
two days of training
that comprise because that's a fair
amount of training two days
and an examination following it i'd be
interested to see
maybe a summary of what what was
involved there please thank you
thank you
thank you chair uh yeah i'll just answer
those two
uh points that raise their questions uh
the first one yes very much so along
similar lines to the safeguarding
training
it's about creating as much awareness
out there amongst officers and members
and we are a bridge we are a bridge to
other expert services so if we can have
a similar level of success that we have
in creating that network from a broader
safeguarding perspective
in relation to mental health and i think
will be a good way along
to a better place in terms of the
training yes you're right
the two-day mental health first aid
training is
quite uh involved and
it picks up on many of the things that
other members have said
on council today including council
hancock who began to list
the various complexities so for from our
mental health
two day trained people of which there
are few
fewer uh i'm one that one of them but it
does go into all of those
complexities and at this stage we've
chosen to leave that
out of the
strategy as it's as it is today but
certainly
in terms of the knowledge understanding
awareness around the various
complexities then
it is held within a certain number of
staff the broader training
that we've put in place is more about
awareness in the same way we deal with
safeguarding generally uh taking on
board uh councillor barry's comments
earlier on
in terms of overloading people with
information and too much
you have to pitch training at different
levels i guess
depending on the individuals
and as a broader council in terms of
getting people trained up to a certain
level there's a lot of commitment
required depending on the degree and
content so yes absolutely in terms of
member training we envisage this being
rolled out in a similar way to
safeguarding training house
today
thank you councillor ruff do you wish to
use your right of reply
thank you chair i welcome all the
comments that have been raised
it is an early stage and i welcome
susie cornwell's interest
and maggie jones i'm sure we can all get
together and work to
[Music]
look at ways further for this document
thank you we will now move to the vote
can we have a show of hands please roll
those in paper
yeah that's carried
thank you
i've got some vision derbyshire
thank you chair i was asked a question
by councillor lewis
um yes i do think you need to as you
have done all
district in fact all county council
members should declare an interest
you will know the nature of the interest
in relation to the report
if it's not significant you will stay
speak and vote
if it is significant you will have to
leave
but this applies to all county council
members
sorry yeah sarah did what what did you
say i just
caught that all county council members
then
sorry because this is an issue that
affects the county council
you will have to consider what kind of
interest you have to declare council
lewis raised the point at the beginning
and it's for you to decide whether you
think it's significant or not
if you don't think it's significant you
can stay speak and vote if you do think
it's significant you would leave the
meeting
okay thank you
listen sorry
are there near their declaration of
interest
i'll uh if if i may chair i'll
declare the same interests as council
lewis although i i don't believe it's
significant enough for me to not
participate in the
in the debate um uh so i will i will
stay and
participate and vote thank you
uh anjali foster council hoster
yes chair uh thank you yet uh
same point really i'll declare an
interest as a
cabinet membership county council
however i don't think that it's a
significant
interest and i'm happy to stay in the
debate
council
so is councillor lewis then leaving the
meeting at this point
uh just to clarify from hm and i'll be
staying in the uh
in the meeting and the debate and i'll
take a view about the voters are here
as we work through the debate but i
think on looking at the report
i should be okay to vote
are there other counter counselors
sure i did put in chat box like
uh council right here i declare
my interest as a county councillor it's
not there's no significant
issues what will we raise so i shall be
staying in the meeting
and i will be able to vote thank you
are there any more
yeah um i wonder if you could explain
how three
county council cabinet members are able
to sit in this meeting
and claim that they don't have some form
of significant interest in what
we agree
hello and over too
it's one of those situations where it's
for the member to decide in the
they know the nature of their business
as a county councillor you've all seen
the report
the individual makes the decision
thank you
this item was marked to follow on your
agendas and has been published in the
supplementary
agenda before i invite councillor dale
to present the report
the iacon will be giving a short
presentation
thank you thank you chair uh
it won't be a long presentation if nikki
can just allow me to
share screen
uh can everyone see that
can you see that sarah you just give me
a nod his own screen
thank you very much
okay so just before council dale
presents the report in
what it might be useful to just give a
little bit more background in terms of
what's actually
been happening in terms of vision
derbyshire so
it was around 18 months ago when the
council along with
all of the derbyshire councils embarked
on an exploration of future
collaborative
uh working uh it was a program that was
built
upon the pres premise uh the
collaboration and collaboration at scale
could go on to achieve better outcomes
for the communities that each
council serves pricewaterhousecooper
were commissioned to support this
program which would be conducted in a
series of phases
so phase one included all ten councils
uh and the intention was to identify the
priorities
of each of the councils the level of
ambition and appetite
that there might be to progress with
what was called at the time
non-structural reform
which then went on and resulted in the
development
of the broad principles for
collaboration
which included various uh benefits
but not least a viable alternative to
unitarization
potential areas for future collaboration
and these included tourism
the visitor economy skills and
employment
and climate change amongst others and
the critical success factors
that might be necessary including the
ability to work at pace
uh working as a collective
and in a way that was not classed as
business as usual
phase two following uh
a bit of a pause the program was
reinitiated
in march 2020 uh and derby city
declined to uh continue at that point
so it was all of the other councils with
the exception of derby city
a series of workshops were rolled out
which included senior officers and
leaders from across the county
and these were always aimed at testing
the emerging
collaboration model and to begin to set
out the plans for the future
of what was to become known as vision
derbyshire
from these workshops four key ambitions
were developed
and these were as they are say on screen
seizing innovation
establishing relentless ambition
building proactive communities
and living and working sustainably
here are the key ambitions in a little
bit more detail so seasoned innovation
was around building the physical
digital uh and knowledge assets and
infrastructure to support the new
industries
uh that would be fit for the future and
attracting inward investment
and facilitating place-based networks
between business and educational
institutions
and entrepreneurs and workforce to spark
innovation
establishing relentless ambition was
about raising the aspirations of all
young people in derbyshire
and supporting and empowering them to
acquire future improved skills
and trainings to be successful and
support an innovative and diverse
economy individuals would use these
skills and energy to give back to their
communities and the local areas
and overall derbyshire would become an
attractive place
to live work and play and known for its
blend of green space
diverse economy and job opportunities
and quality of life
and community spirit in terms of
building
uh proactive communities this was
empowering local communities
enabling them to be self-organizing uh
and building economic uh and
an emotional resilience against external
influences and empowering
uh those communities and individuals uh
to utilize available
uh technology uh and well-being
knowledge
uh and uh infrastructure
such as the green spaces that we have
and living and working sustainably which
will hear a little bit more about
it later in the presentation this was
had a focus on affordable housing uh
economic growth and physical assets
and the responsibility of the economic
and emotional resilience
being shared amongst communities
businesses and local government
with mutual recognition and finally
people
prioritizing sustainable lifestyles
balancing work and play
and using and rebuilding assets and
making good life choices
those are the four key ambitions of what
underpins vision derbyshire
so the work the work shops then went on
to focus upon well
okay we know what we want to achieve
what do we need
in order to be able to achieve that and
here you see on screen a list of
that enablers be required uh for for the
ambitions to be realized
each of these uh have uh
or will be become a work stream in their
own right
and along with the enablers it was felt
that
there may have to be certain asks of
government
provision derbyshire to develop and be
truly
effective so
in terms of the living and working
sustainably uh
work stream uh aligned to the
uh original premise of being able to
collaborate at scale and improving the
outcomes for
our communities a series of pilot
projects
uh have been explored that will
hopefully
demonstrate this i've been appointed as
the lead officer as part of this
programme
for this living and working sustainably
theme
along with councillor amos william who's
the leader of
amber valley borough council
in terms of the these pilot projects
that you see on the screen these are
three programs that are currently under
development so the first one
is a thanks to tom campaign which is
all about raising awareness and then
getting in the community
to commit and sign up to reducing their
carbon footprint
by a ton so in terms of impact
in terms of climate change impact that
is
uh it's hoped that we can demonstrate
that
by collaborating as a county we can
vastly increase our reach uh and improve
the uptake and and
obviously the level of commitment on a
county-wide footprint
second one there is healthy homes this
is aimed at
external wall insulation uh and
internal wall insulation for that matter
uh earth
are non-traditional solid wall
hard to treat homes so it's acknowledged
uh
and understood that across the county
most districts and boroughs have got a
vast amount of these properties
and it's one of the single biggest
things that we can do as local
authorities to
reduce carbon emissions is getting the
energy
uh our homes in our communities more
efficient
this has got the potential to be a
national um sort of
example if you like of people coming
together and when we
consider the lifetime savings of um
or lifetime reduction of carbon
throughout this program it's into the
millions of tons so
hopefully this has got the opportunity
to become a flagship program
to be funded through central government
uh under this
programme of work and the final one
there
electric vehicle charging points every
borough
and every district across the county is
currently working to
put in place um electric vehicle
charging infrastructure
it feels as though it's done in a
non-joined up way and
as in as individual organizations we
appear to be approaching this on a
as and when opportunities arise and the
idea
of approaching this on a county
county-wide basis again
it it will bring forward efficiencies
through procurement
it will appear more attractive to
central government
and other funding bodies and finally it
would have been a co
be done in a coordinated way so in terms
of rollout
uh and as i say uh procurement but
underpinning
these two uh healthy arms program and
the electric vehicle charging points
does align very strongly with the
ambition
for the whole region really to
be investing in uh
greener economic growth and often the
challenge there is about having a steady
stream and pipeline
of work that allows businesses in these
sectors
to have the confidence to grow
so with a pipeline of work that could be
identified and funded
through these sort of programs also
gives business the confidence to grow
in order to meet that demand
and i'm happy to take any questions
but that's it for me chair thank you
very much
thank you
councillor dale um
would you like to present the report and
move the recommendations
thank you thank you chair and thanks uh
lee for the presentation i hope people
found it useful
i mean i would say that um just a short
introduction to say that
um i think vision derbyshire remains a
very exciting agenda there's still a lot
of engagement from across the
uh the eight councils that are involved
um i would still say despite it being
having gone for sort of 18 months it's
still at fairly early stages it's
it's largely at the moment a broad
framework
or for collaboration at scale there's
still a lot of detail to work through
and obviously of course any any detailed
matters such as structure or governance
will come back to full council
uh for any approval that that would
clearly be a
decision for council to make um but
based on what's been happening so far i
think it's it's showing some good
progress
there are some really good pilot
projects there that lee's indicated
where
clearly collaborate collaboration at
scale has
a huge amount of benefit to not just
ourselves but all of
the councils across derbyshire um so
really the report speaks for itself it's
only a sort of in principle
uh support to continue to engage with
the process i'd like to
have councils backing to continue to
have a seat at the table in the
discussions and hear what's happening
and be involved
and obviously any matters of detail such
as structure or governance will come
back to full council for
sign off and and for everyone to agree
with i think i appreciate that some
some members may have concerns over
vision derbyshire and i think
you know i have concerns in on the basis
of what we actually put on the table and
what that governance looks like so i
share some of those
uh some of those news from some of you
and obviously i would want to see that
we are involved in the shaping of what
vision derbyshire looks like so that we
can get the most out of it
and if it's if it turns into something
that we're not happy with then i'm
perfectly happy that we that we walk
away but
at the moment it's it's early stages um
it's still being worked up and i think
it's showing itself through
those pilot projects that it really can
achieve some huge benefits for the whole
county so i would like um effectively
council to support
our continued engagement with it and
obviously come back to a future full
council when there is more detail
to uh to go through and to to discuss
and decide where we where we go next
so i'm happy to remove the the report
and obviously we'll take any questions
in the
in the right to reply at the end chair
thank you
thank you is there a second
that's a cute picture that's
councillor barker
yeah thank you chair uh yeah interesting
alex uh yeah and and obviously we'll
support you in that and i think
uh it's it's a paper a good paper
uh and and i'm pleased that the the
concept of the structural reform that
will be muted
as uh has been part uh i'm not sure
it'll
it's gone away all together forever but
uh
it's one of those things that will be a
perennial
thing i'm sure but as it stands and the
paper as it is
uh uh uh we we can support that
and i know you you've already mentioned
it in your comments on
the 2.8 about bringing anything back
to council for formal approval so
obviously that's in there and and we'll
make sure that
that's it and uh i you know it's not
going to be a perfect scenario
eight councils working together all from
different
political persuasions but i think from
where i'm picking up everybody's buying
into it because
it's the preferred option to the
alternative so
it's not going to be easy but we've got
to make it work alex and
uh best of luck we and and i'll support
the recommendations thank you
thank you councillor brian wright
thank you jay yes uh council back has
mentioned the importance what are we
going to stress well on
uh paragraph 2.8 about bringing any
details etc back
to full council but i'd just like to add
to that that i am i'm currently the
shadow cabinet member for
what covers climate change as well as
well excuse me
uh so uh like on the thanks uh
ton uh alex uh i'll obviously be taking
a keen interest in that and would like
to be kept in the loop
because of the cabin reduction challenge
etc so that we can
all be singing from the same song sheet
on that one thank you
that's just all i wanted to read
you councillor dale do you wish to use
your right of reply
sorry i think councillor shipman and
council hancock may want to come in so
i'll
i'll happily defer to them first if
that's okay right counter shipment
thank you chair um i think at this stage
i'll be supporting this i think it's
worth exploring
so we can try and work together with
other councils even if it
doesn't work out that way in practice so
um i'll be supporting it at this stage
and we'll see what comes back in future
council rank thank you chair
yeah to echo everyone else um
at this stage it is very very draft
i'm happy to support it i mean my big
concerns to be truthful
are i mean yes i i absolutely oppose the
unity i think
that the county is too diverse for us to
even go down that route
my concerns here is that we have very
little in common with the likes of high
peak and of course it's seeing how that
collaboration will take form
but i think as a council we have to
endorse
councillor dale's ability to take this
forward so that those discussions can be
had
and that those concerns can be raised
and that he can come back to us with
those solutions
thank you any more comments can i just
write something please
john councillor for now
yeah i think the the vision derbyshire
is is the right route and it keeps
things
momentum moving i'm not sure it's the
right question for this
uh this group but do we know what's
happening
at county council level what route are
they
proposing and what are they doing the
last thing we
heard were they were going to write uh
to the secretary i just wondered whether
what are they doing
is that in parallel with what we're
doing or against what we're doing
council adele do you wish to use your
right reply
uh yeah thank you jeff i'll try and
cover all of those points so
firstly just to thank all members for
the the general and principal support uh
i think we we all agree that it's right
that we continue to engage and see what
uh what comes back um a counselor writes
comments around
um the thanks campaign some of the green
um green initiatives i'm sure we can
uh liaise with you to ensure that you
are kept up to speed and
councillor kenyon uh who's leading on uh
on the the northeast harborship uh
approach to thanksgiving i'm sure we'll
um we'll be happy to to have a chat with
you about that
um councillor hancock's comments um
are very valid i think the the diversity
of the county is the important
point and hopefully um vision derbyshire
will take that into account in that it
will
not only be a collaboration at scale in
terms of the whole county but
it it it contains the flexibility for
smaller groups of councils to
collaborate
on different issues so uh much as we
have now with bowls over in the
strategic alliance or with chesterfield
as well in the joint board
or with the dales as well in the ict
framework we sort of can have that
that patchwork of different forms of
collaboration depending on
on the issue and and actually who's got
the stomach to to do it as well i
suppose of all the different councils so
um that that flexibility is built in
hopefully to what i've seen
so far revision derbyshire and in terms
of the county's approach
uh uh it's council for now that the the
county's position remains that the
vision derbyshire is the
uh preferred option for local government
performing um
in in in derbyshire and that's what's
being pursued as far as i'm aware so
i hope that that answers the query there
um so yeah happy to
to move to the voucher thank you
thank you we'll now move to the boat can
i have a show of hands please
all those in favor
appears to be unanimous chair
[Music]
thank you
item 10 emergency delegations can i
invite the monitoring officer to present
the report
thank you thank you chair at the time we
went into the first lockdown in march
a number of emergency delegations were
put in place by using the particular
delegation quoted at 1.1
this was because there were were no
member meetings for a time
and we needed to be able to take action
in certain areas these powers have now
lapsed but there is a requirement in the
constitution
to report back to you on the use of the
power instigating them
so you can see on page 55 where they
were used to put the emergency powers
in place and in relation to one council
tax issue
but on page 56 is a list of the
decisions actually taken
these are all on the website and it's
not actually a requirement to report
these decisions back but for the
fullness of the report we've done so
um latest version of the emergency
powers
so that you know what we were talking
about are on pages 68 to 71
and it is as i say a constitutional
requirement to report back on the use of
these powers
so the recommendation is that you note
the decisions that have been made
and just to repeat those are the
decisions being that being made at 1.2
thank you
thank you may i have a mover and a
second
i'm sorry
any questions at council dale
just to say i'm happy to move the report
but obviously if there's any questions
for sarah i'll i'll wait to do so if
that's better
thank you
councillor barker has indicated his wish
to speak
when uh sort of extraordinary challenge
and i know we've got all the
emergency powers sorry counts about can
i have a second there
oh sorry
how's the council
thank you councillor barker sorry
switch me mike off that i'm uh i'm in
reverse
every yeah i know it's extraordinary
times i don't know
i keep reading through this uh to be
honest just to see if i can
spot any anything that's uh a bit there
to order and
uh uh basically we we we trust you on on
what's
you know the powers that you can use
under these delegate powers
and i know council of airkin has got a
couple of questions as well
so the only one for me and it does link
into
what we'll probably talk about next time
is is the council dispensation on the
7th of may
i don't quite what happened there
sarah can you just explain in a bit more
detail
and also another question have the
emergency powers run out now then or
are they are you going to have to renew
them
sorry thank you thank you yeah to answer
the last one first yes they ran
out in november we've not renewed them
since we carried them on for a little
while
just in case but we've completely gone
now because we do have these virtual
meetings there's not a need for them um
the dispensation will be the one that's
the subject of the report to accounts
until next time
the dispensation delegated decision
okay i thought it might be thank you
okay i know councillor berkins wanted to
can i have cancer shipment first
thank you cheerio i i just wanted to say
tonight and i've said this
before to the monitoring officer that
i'm so disappointed today's talk
from the 30th of march well the first
delegation was on the 25th of march
2020 it's taken until
the 11th of january 2021
to report that these decisions have been
taken because the the
uh i think it's local government where
they need reporting this is
the earliest opportunity or the next
opportunity
well we've had a meeting in july uh
september october november now we've got
one now why
what the reason i was given was because
we've got one
one member of staff less in the
governance department well i'm not being
funny
these are delegated powers that we are
being
kept out of so the first thing that
should be on that agenda
is for officers putting these decisions
in front of council so
we know what's been done by this council
i don't think
the reasons i've been given are
acceptable and i think when this report
comes back accounts for the next meeting
this investigation
i think it needs to take a serious hard
look at itself about what actually
has happened so it doesn't happen again
in future
thank you yes indeed council shipman has
expressed his disquiet that it's um
taken until now for us to come to you to
you to use his term
however would point out these powers
were enforced until the end of november
they were active they um have all been
done openly and transparency and
transparently in accordance with the
delegated
powers what we do um the ones the actual
decisions which are not the subject of
this report but are given you for
background information
on page 56 they've all been published on
the website
so it's not something that's been kept
secret or whatever
and as to take until now to come back
well yes
um we've it has been a very difficult
period setting up these virtual meetings
as everybody in the country will tell
you are not easy
and they're officer intensive some
things have been delayed you have to
prioritize
thank you councillorship
burkhead thank you chair uh
council joe burke in sutton world um i
agree with councillor shipman i'm a
little bit
disappointed with the information than
the that we've just had
um mr sternberg says that uh it's all
been transparent but we've only just
been told about it as councillor shipman
said after 11 months
um i as in as uh invited on page 56
uh of the report i attempted to view uh
some of these uh
decisions i looked at six of them
uh for five of them the message came up
either no results
or that it was restricted so
transparency is a little bit
uh questionable when it says that i'm as
a as a sitting counselor i've been
restricted from
looking at any of these items the one
that i did
managed to pick out was about the
building works on chesterfield road
and there was a reference there to the
earlier decision that had been taken
when i looked at that then that came out
and said there were no results available
as well
so uh i'm very disappointed that um
that we can't uh get on this cam sorry
mr sternberg said it's on the
website it's not on the website it's not
as i said
not been able to get uh over half of the
well about half of the information
that's there could i
and i found it difficult to believe that
0.1.7 on page 56
that these decisions are not required to
be reported on
um that could be anything
could there be anything that any member
or officer has decided to
to do for um for whatever reasons i
would think it'd be most important that
these are properly reported upon
so i'd ask that a report is given to us
on the decisions that were made
and by whom for our next council meeting
please thank you
i might come back to him that chair on
the last point
no we don't report back delegated
decisions as standard it is only a
requirement
in relation to the emergency planning
delegation which is quoted to you at 1.2
so as i said before those decisions on
page
56 my screen's gone are there for your
information to show you the sort of
things that these powers will use for
they're not there because we're
reporting them back to you
in terms of not being able to get it on
the website etc i will pick that point
up
because i was under the impression that
you would be able to see it on the
website so i will find out about that
and come back to you on it but in terms
of what's reported about we do not
report back every delegated decision
if we did we might as well come to you
as a council with every single decision
and that would be an awful lot of
business so a lot of it is done
under delegated decision and it should
be advertised on the website if it's an
open
issue so i will check into that one and
get back to you
thank you are there any further comments
councillor hancock
thank you chair and i know this is
coming back to us but i am going to pick
up on the same thing because it is a
huge issue
is is this dispensation which obviously
does have significant legal
repercussions
it has had significant legal
repercussions already
in that we have lost a member due to it
so the fact that that hasn't been
reported back
it was taken as a decision that
officers would not normally take it
would normally be a decision
in legislation required by council
so i am going to bang the same drummers
as my colleagues
from from both my own party and from the
labour party
absolutely these should not have been
withheld this long and
and with no disrespect at all to uh to
the monitoring officer
to say that it can't be reported back in
that time scale is absolute lunacy i
mean
how long does it take to list half a
dozen items at various meetings it's
it's a 10-minute job it really is i mean
this is just a table it's it's not even
got the full detail that
that is not a labor-intensive job by any
stretch of anyone's imagination
can i just re-emphasize one point
further again
page 56 lists delegated decisions there
is no requirement to report back on
those to counsel
they are there to give you an indication
of what the emergency delegations were
for
yes if you have all the time in the
world it's not a difficult or lengthy
report to write
we simply didn't have all the time in
the world and that is a matter of fact
thank you chair could i raise something
again
uh you've already just sorry but you've
already spoken
at country birkin point of order then
chair
which um which part of the constitution
has been breached
i apologize i don't know that distance
that that
detail but i would i would just say
that the the information given on page
56
is not details of what decisions are
being made there's no detail in the
chesterfield roadmap to what on earth
does that mean
it's nonsense
we will now move to the vote
you know please ask members to
give a show of hands for
can we do it by paul thank you
thank you chair i've now launched the
the polling for members
to vote either for against or abstain
that the council note the decisions made
under emergency delegated powers
just have a few more members who'd like
to cast their votes
chair i'm going to stop the pulling now
and just share that with you
um so including the two votes within the
chamber
that would be 37 votes four three
against with eight abstentions
which means that those recommendations
have been carried
thank you
foreign
[Music]
point 11 to answer any questions from
members under procedure rule 9.2
i can confirm that no questions have
been submitted from members we will move
to the next item
and that is to consider an emotion from
members under procedure rule 10 and i
can confirm that we have received
one motion for today's meeting can i
invite
councillor cornwell to move the motion
uh thank you very much chair um i'm
councillor susie cornwell representing
heath and homewood
and i'm honored to be bringing this
motion forward
on behalf of the charity crohn's and
colitis uk
and on behalf of 300 000 people in the
uk
who have this disease and sophie
fletcher of north wingfield
who wrote to a district councillor and
has asked us to bring this motion
i see this as local democracy in action
and for those of you who don't know
i hope you will allow me the opportunity
to tell you a bit about the disease
crohn's and colitis are two forms of
inflammatory bowel disease
and they are lifelong diseases of the
gut they are painful
debilitating and widely misunderstood
there is no no cure and they're not
classed as a disability
when you have crohn's or colitis your
immune system doesn't work properly
your body starts attacking itself it
causes ulcers and inflammations in the
gut
these conditions affect almost every
part of your body
and every aspect of your life
another need to use the toilet is the
main symptom
of living with this disease and people
are often faced with anxieties such as
having an accident in public
being refused toilet access being
confronted
about why they're using an accessible
and accessible facility
one in two people with crohn's or
colitis
have received negative comments for
using accessible toilets
so the motion before council today is
because of the stigma and the
misunderstanding
surrounding invisible conditions and to
support those thousands of people who
are suffering in silence
being subjected to discrimination and
sometimes harassment
just for trying to use the accessible
toilet they urgently need
so through their campaign not every
disability is visible
the charity wants to change the signs on
accessible toilets
it's actually the sign that's behind me
it wants to change it on the toilet
doors to help people with invisible
conditions feel confident using these
essential facilities
i've often thought if something doesn't
affect you then yeah you have no idea on
how this really affects you as a person
or affects a person's life and as
counselors
our job is to make informed decisions
and to make northeast derbyshire
better for our residents now my husband
lives with this
every day it is utterly debilitating
disease
and on a daily basis the need to know
that he is not far from the toilet that
he can use
is paramount in his mind every minute
of every day so let's just take it take
a moment to think about that
sophie fletcher my husband 300 000
people in the uk
every minute of every day have to plan
their life around whether they are close
to a toilet
so can you imagine then when they're in
pain
and when they're in need how they feel
when somebody
challenges them to to and they have to
use their radar key
or show this card to say urgent
can't wait it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing saying these words in a
council chamber
but not half as embarrassing as needing
the toilet and being refused access to
the toilet
because you don't look disabled and
knowing the consequences of not being
allowed to use the toilet
or being frowned on and told no you're
not disabled
you can't use that toilet so
this campaign has is about installing
these signs
in supermarkets retail areas airports
railway service stations
they're now calling on restaurants and
pubs and
across the country to do the same olden
oldham
and manchester council have also
installed them so by supporting not
every disability is visible
northeast derbyshire will be making the
visible invisible
just like the t-shirt that i'm wearing
so let our
council pave the way for people to visit
and work in our building
that recognizes their disability by
bearing the new type of say
sign and by training our staff let's
spread this word to all our parishes and
the facilities that we run
and let's work closely with the retail
and restaurant
sector the charity asking for something
so simple and so cheap to implement
i urge the council to support this
motion
and the amendment that's proposed by
council hancock
and make our district a safe place for
those with this invisible disease
thank you very much for listening to me
i'm sorry it took a few minutes
but it's really important to me
can i second that chair and i'll can i
reserve and come back and speak at the
end please
yes thank you councillor barker i've
been i've been informed that there are
some
people who require a comfort break
could i interrupt her and just say can
we have
two minutes pause thank you
so members you're welcome to turn your
cameras off and mute for the next couple
of minutes
thank you chair it's council martian
thacker representing brampton and walton
ward
the motion refers to crohn's disease and
colitis
there are many other hidden disabilities
which may
cause continence issues and may require
the use of an accessible toilet
these categories as highlighted by
access for all uk
are diverticulitis which affects one in
ten people
over the age of forty five
stoma whereas there are a hundred and
two thousand people in the uk
autism of which there are 700 000 people
in the uk
learning disabilities it's one and a
half million people
with 350 000 having severe learning
disabilities
and dementia 850 000 people
in the uk when you add these finger
figures to the number of people with
crohn's disease that's one in 650 people
and colitis at least 146 000 people
the numbers are very significant
there is a misunderstanding by some that
access
accessible toilets are solely for the
use of wheelchair users
a change of signage to highlight that
facilities are for the use of people
with hidden abilities too
would be extremely helpful and i support
the introduction
of the signage suggested
training that enables people to
understand the need for accessible
toilets
and use by people with hidden
disabilities
would also be an excellent step
access for all uk maintains that
training should emphasize the needs of
the wider population
who may require use of accessible
toilets
and this is something our council should
be mindful of
turning to changing places toilets
changing places toilets are needed by at
least 250
000 people in the uk better signage
is an extremely welcome suggestion
changing places awareness training is
beneficial
often facilities are installed at venues
without any awareness training being
given to venue staff
who are then not aware of what these
vital facilities are
who needs them and why
they are also unable to signpost them to
those who may need them
monitor maintain or promote them
effectively i'm sure counselor cornwell
will accept my comments
as further examples of the invisible
conditions referred to in the motion
and as suggestions to be born in mind by
officers
when considering implementation
i welcome this motion and wholeheartedly
support it thank you chair
can i ask councillor wendla thanks
please
thank you chair um council of hackers
said more or less all that i was going
to say
as well i totally endorse this
i embrace it and there are so many other
conditions medical conditions
and disabilities that don't necessarily
mean that the person
needs a wheelchair and consultants at
the hospital will very often advise that
did you realize that you you can
have a radar key for this condition
so i really support this motion i would
just ask and i think
um councillor cromwell is
already aware that um i would
uh also like including
in in what uh the motion is the reasons
is that um we
endeavor to try and get the signage
low enough so that people in wheelchairs
can actually
see it i have come across some changing
places
where it's it's too high and you can't
expect someone that's sat in a
wheelchair to see it
people that can walk probably will but
not the people in wheelchairs
but it's an excellent motion and i fully
agree with it
thank you
counselor window when are you asking
somebody
to make an amendment or to answer it yes
yes i think um councilman cromwell's
probably already aware
that we've asked to be added to
uh my i thought it was councillor
hancock that was bringing it so
and i did yeah he he did it he sent it
on on my behalf initially
and but yes yes for clarity the
governance officer was going to bring it
up on screen
yeah yeah would you like me to do that
now yes please
yes please
[Applause]
uh so where is the proposed um amendment
members
in green right okay
councillor hancock do you want to speak
yes if i can second that chair
um it's purely case obviously we're
talking about hidden
disabilities we need to ensure obviously
we don't forget
the visible disabilities and whilst this
amendment is a very very minor one
um we have seen instances elsewhere in
other local authorities
where they have failed to address this
issue and
uh and the uh the signs have been placed
far too high for wheelchair users to
actually see them
um other than that obviously as has
already been said by councillor windley
and councillor thacker i think
every single person in in the in the
meeting
backs backs the motion and uh and i
think it it's a very positive step
forward and
and as a forward-looking council we
should we should lead the way
so that's all i've got to say chair
thank you
and that can i say as the satanic to the
original motion that i agree with the
amendment
so it's no confusion that's very helpful
that's mark i was just about to come in
and say strictly speaking this is an
amendment which we'd vote on debate and
vote on
but if the mover in the second and the
consensus of the meeting is that it
should be added
if you just show by wayney and we'll
just add it to the main motion
are you happy for that yeah
everybody seems happy yeah
we'll take that as the amended motion
then
okay councillor parker
parking parking sorry
councillor paul parkin representing
north thank you very much jay um yes
i'd like to thank susie for bringing
this uh bringing this motion
to council today um i have a very
personal reason for
wanting to ensure that this council
supports
uh these invisible
problems that are encountered when
when people need to use these this these
facilities
and a colleague at work uh just before
christmas
um she had um
she had some very very severe uh issues
uh and uh without going into massive
details
uh uh it went from went from being
a comfortable situation before to an
extremely painful situation
and difficult situation very rapidly for
this particular individual
um i i wholeheartedly
support uh now i understand
and i if if anybody on the council
currently doesn't understand the need
i would suggest you have a look at some
of the
uh material online but the the
i wholeheartedly support uh the notices
and the spirit of the solution uh and
will be voting for it thank you for
bringing it forward susie
thank you councillor leggett
uh council representative
i'd like to add my thanks to uh
councillor cornwall as well as my father
at crohn's disease and my mother has
diverticulitis
and i too have flare-ups and i am one of
those people
that once had to use a disabled toilet
and was
attacked aggressively on leaving so i
i am very very grateful for the this
this coming forward thank you
thank you councillor birkin
thank you chair um with no disrespect to
the
chair i just want to raise a couple of
points one is uh
sorry and um to add to what council
attacker said
uh spinal injury patients uh are a very
large number
uh that have problems uh i myself have a
spinal injury a spinal cord
injury which means i am one of those
partially disabled people i'm what's
known as a walker
because i don't need a wheelchair but i
do have other problems
and i've used accessible toilets myself
i've been
challenged as well as to why i've had to
do that
um and apologies chair but two minutes
isn't enough for a comfort break
seriously you need to
people need to think about that as well
thank you
council cornwell do you wish to exercise
your right of reply
uh only to say uh the irony wasn't lost
on me that we had a comfort break the
moment i finished speaking
and maybe i should have used the
opportunity to invite everyone to have a
comfort break
prior to my to that and also just to say
um thank you to all those that have
spoken i can see there's a lot of
support within the
the council for this um i don't assume
it's going to be an issue when it comes
to the vote
i wasn't um purposely ignoring all those
other disabilities i was just trying to
represent
uh the crohn's and colitis uk who had to
actually actually brought this
and for sophie fletcher who brought it
to our attention
um and got us to do it can i just show
you all for one moment
this is the sign that we're voting on
and below
it says not every disability is visible
thank you thank you
councillor barker you wish to speak yeah
yeah i just didn't tweet when i when i
seconded it
and i think well it's great that that
everybody's going to support it and i'll
just
make the point i'm usually not in favor
of these round robins when somebody
sends you a
fully written resolution to council but
obviously you can see that it's a
personal
for some of our councillors it's an
issue that does
come in and there's somebody that's
that's drove a mini bus full of folks
with
learning disabilities and disabilities
these changing places have uh
been a relief and that's upon that that
that's a that's
because when you somebody wants to go
and but they're not publicized very well
uh every public building has probably
got
a disabled toilet but you're never quite
sure so
the more we can get this signage out so
if there is somebody riding around with
a car full or a mini bus full of folks
that at least they know where they can
they can go so uh thanks again it sounds
like it's going to go through so
thank you and and let's hope we can
i know it's it's a big ass when you're
asking private
concerns to do it but we can influence
all that can't we
thank you
councillor barry you wish to speak
thank you um well it was to thank
everybody for
taking us on board um because i said
sophie did
uh write into us at north wingfield in
relation to this
um but what i think um i'm accepting
everybody's going to vote on this but my
next thing would be
uh you know could we be looking at time
scales for getting this action
um because we've got a lot of buildings
um
and we don't want to leave it hanging in
the balance uh we've we've made a great
decision or we will do shortly
so i'd like to make sure that it gets
enacted as soon
as possible uh and i'm not sure whether
we should even be looking at this in a
braille format as well
for those that are sight impaired um
but just about the time scales and if
the officers could take this on board
and move with it rather quickly
thank you thank you we are going to go
to the boat but i'd just like to bring
back in councillor windley
yeah um
um there is a site that you can
um actually visit changing places and it
will
show you all the changing places
that are around the uk if you're
traveling around
it's quite useful
anymore so hopefully i'll not be in that
situation
no but for anybody else that's listening
it is there
is that there is a site there changing
places thanks chair
thank you can we now move to the boat
and we have
our show of hands all those in favor
that's carrie chair
all those against anyone
no i think it was unanimous thank you
thank you very much everyone
thank you
now
i will now move that the public be
excluded from the meeting
calling the item of business to avoid
the disclosure
to them of exempt information as defined
in paragraphs one
and two part one of schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972 as
amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
i have a secondary councillor hacker
yes our second chair we will
now vote by show of hands
paul sorry okay i want to say something
else if that's okay
cancer shipment um i
i don't understand what's exempting here
i'm looking all the information that i'm
looking at
is information about how this the
killer marsh sports center is running at
the moment and
they're going to be taking out loans for
it i don't see what why
any of that would be exactly but surely
it's in the public interest
they hear the debate and see
what what it is they're talking about
because what they're gonna get is they
ultimately we're spending their money
and we're committed into
potentially a lease or other
arrangements with taxpayers money
both organizations in this deal are
tax payer funded so can you tell me can
you make me understand why any of this
is exempt
i can see why there might be an issue
for private companies who are involved
because what we're discussing might
affect you know share prices and all
sorts of things
but this we are talking about two public
sector
bodies and about one taking out a loan
to enter into an arrangement with
another one
i would like to see a vote or is going
to uh
whether we're going into example because
i don't believe we can and i don't
believe any characters sat around this
table can honestly justify
was going into exemption over this
count councillor dale
councillor dale thank you thank you chad
i'm sure um sarah can give her more
detailed uh reply but my understanding
is that the
in terms of the killer march paper uh
it's for reasons of commercial
sensitivity these are not private
organizations but they are in direct
competition with private organizations
and it's a extremely competitive
marketplace uh in terms of the other
paper it's in relation to
staffing matters so it it it makes sense
that that is dealt with in
uh uh you know in exempts uh information
as per typical but um sarah's monitoring
officer might be able to provide more
information that's my understanding
anyway
thank you thank you chair yes that's
entirely correct
um paragraph three particularly schedule
12a talks about the financial affairs of
the authority not just private sector
businesses
so it's it's both authorities that have
commercial sensitivities
for that particular report and it is
usual to do um
employment related ones under those
paragraphs in exempt business
because of course it's not a full con
conclusion that members will agree with
it
in terms of the vote itself you you
express council shipment a desire
to have a vote to have it in public you
don't need that if you vote against
putting it into exam business it will
remain open as a meeting
but it is for members to decide whether
they wish whether it's in the public
interest
to go into exempt business or to stay
open
so i have now moved that may have a
secondary
uh chair i i will i will second for
clarity though and and
i think i think that the issue that
council shipment is raising obviously
the staffing issue
should be confidential but the killer
marsh leisure center one
i think it's very difficult to justify
that as being
as being something that would be exempt
again for the same reasons that ross has
mentioned they are two public
authorities and we are dealing with
public money here
[Music]
chair may i ask the question please
as a killer marsh member yes
um i fully understand and appreciate why
we shouldn't be allowed to vote um
at the end of the debate that's about to
to come online
but um i fail to see why we can't be
allowed to stay in the room
um and and witness you know the debates
without seeking to influence the outcome
of that debate so can i have clarity on
that please
if i might chair um if i could deal with
council hancock's point first
public authorities or not there is a
need for room for
authorities to consider and decide what
they want to do
that is well recognized in all sorts of
legislation such as freedom of
information legislation you've got to
have that space to come to a conclusion
and that's what section the paragraph
three as well as naming the individuals
under one and two
that's what it is providing a safe space
for the council to consider what it
wants to do
with commercially sensitive details in
terms of the interest
council pots i'm afraid we're stuck with
the constitution which requires members
to leave the chamber
in a physical meeting you would have to
physically leave the chamber
this is no different you will just have
to leave the zoom meeting
i'm sorry thank you check can i just
reiterate i did second it
yeah a short while ago and uh so it's
seconded again
yes now we'll have a second we will now
vote
councillor whitehead sorry yeah good
chair um
yes just regarding the uh safe space
that uh sarah was just alluded to
we are in slightly different times where
that we will
leave the meeting and then watch the
meeting on youtube
which is a bit strange so we're not
going to be
in fact no that isn't correct isn't it
because coming out of well
well until we've decided whether it's
going into private session or not i
suppose it
that one's up in the air um but
i would support um being a killer marsh
parish councillor
and a northeast killer marsh councillor
i would support that this um
motion is debate is debated in public
because
it is uh largely impacting two
authorities
and the um interest in the public
is quite widespread and there's a danger
that
this whole process will be done
in private session um without public
scrutiny
so obviously i think it's down to the
members now to decide whether
that that will take place or not but
let's be clear that we don't want
decisions being taken
on significant grounds that
affect the public behind closed doors
are there any other speakers chair yes
please
counselor kenyan councillor cannon
i would just like to say that um it's
also about the employees that work at
the
leisure centre and i think for that
reason if no other reason it should be
exempt
thank you counselor
council club do you wish to speak
no well now thank you
sorry i didn't have my hand up this time
um i would like to register my interest
in this i did have my hand up but wasn't
given the option to
to say anything last time
[Music]
thank you we'll now
vote chair could i just ask
on a point do we have a
do we as killer marsh um
parish councillors do we have a vote on
whether this is taken into private
session
um is that an issue
for us to vote on
that's a very good question um i think
the answer is you can vote on moving to
exempt but then you would have to leave
obviously for the killer marsh report
thank you
okay would you like for me to issue the
poll
which i've answered there were some
clarity
[Music]
voting for it is to go into exam voting
against it is to
stay in public forum
yes
we'll go to the poll
all those in favor
so remember i've issued an electronic
poll to you voting for
is to exclude the public for the
remainder of the meeting
against is to vote against that item
just a few more votes to come in
should just be one further vote to be
made
okay i shall end the pulling there and
just share those results with you so we
have two votes four
from the chamber so that would make that
um 34
eight against with nine left tensions
which means
that the uh the motion is carried
um and therefore we will move into
exempt session
thank you you bear with me one moment
here i will just um
stop the live feed
you